[Musique]
le président du département les élus se
sont réunis dans l'hémicycle du palais
de la source ce mercredi 30 octobre en
séance plénière parmi les dossiers
majeurs pour la collectivité le plan
senior qui sera lancé dans les
prochaines semaines on a identifié que
dans l'île avec le vieillissement de la
population on a besoin de personnel
qualifié et donc le département veut
créer va mettre en place un cfa des
métiers des de la personne on va aussi
accompagner les aidants familiaux pour
ce qu' il faut élever le niveau de
qualification
le gramoune au besoin d'être accompagné
il faut des professionnels pour les
accompagner c'est pour cela que nous
allons travailler et on va créer un cfa
dans ce cfa est bien prêt de file du
temple de 5000 personnes seront formées
pour aller travailler dans les
entreprises des dents la personne autre
moment fort les débats autour du plan
agrippé 2020 l'ambition portée par le
département - de faire une agriculture
raisonnée de qualité nous ce que l'on
veut c'est arrivé à l'autonomie ici en
termes de consommation de produits pays
il ya des produits de qualité il faut
les utiliser dans la restauration
scolaire dans toutes les restaurations
collectives
par exemple les hôpitaux partout on veut
inciter à consommer pays et donc oui
cela soutenu notre agriculture c'est le
plan a grippé en lien avec l'état les
agriculteurs et bien sûr l'union
européenne
nous allons porter cette grande ambition
le président a également confirmé la
recentralisation du rsa attendue au 1er
janvier 2020 sur le rsa vous comprenez
bien que chaque année aux dépenses et à
la place de l'étape de 30 millions
d'euros
j'ai demandé cette recentralisation en
lien avec les vice présidents délégués
et le président et le premier ministre
avait bien dit la ministre d outre-mer
que ça se fera au 1er janvier donc au
1er janvier la dépense sera assumé par
l'état et je tiens à rassurer encore une
fois les bénéficiaires il n'y a pas de
changement pour les bénéficiaires
au contraire ce que nous voulons
maintenant nous au département s'est
enclenché un plan d'incitation pour
essayer d'accompagner les bénéficiaires
du rsa vers le monde du travail et donc
par exemple les contrats saisonniers
on va pouvoir les aider à s'il va
l'occuper des contrats saisonniers
pouvoir le faire sans qui communautaire
et ça ça c'est important quoi celles et
ceux qui vont aller se mettre en
formation justement dans les métiers
d'aidé à la personne
eh bien on va pouvoir financer
l'information et il faut pas sauter et
ça paraît une séance plénière qui s'est
terminée par l'annoncé de la mise en
place du plan pétrels soit les vingt
mesures énoncées par le président de la
république visant à lutter contre le
chômage à la réunion
[Musique]